um how is it being in la i saw you wrote
i mean obviously for people who don't
know
uh rolling and controlling shout out to
the rolling 60s
neighborhood rolling 66 straightforward
allegedly allegedly
allegedly back with that allegedly you
know that
yeah but but you you actually came out
here
and and tapped in with you know the the
origins of of
of the role of 60s i saw you know on the
ig store you were over there
uh yesterday shooting a video
how was that man [ __ ] was
to be his life-changing you know because
he's talking to that mike how let's get
that mic right here
you know i've seen all this [ __ ] on like
youtube and
um movies but i ain't never
been nowhere like that like they really
from
the same [ __ ] just a different hood you
see what i'm saying like it's different
city different
states so it was like me going in i felt
right at home
like [ __ ] they showed me love like
i've knew them all my life
yeah i mean you're holding it you're
holding down the uh you know the the set
on the other side
you lift up one of their homies
allegedly you know what i'm saying shout
out to nip though man
um how was that though like because i
think a lot of people
you know l.a obviously you know the
the origins of a lot of gangs are here
you know what i'm saying and
and um did you always have like big
homies that were out here
or like you know i only knew the
neighborhood [ __ ] from
east coast right you know but more or
less
through this rapping it tapped me in
with
well really let me be real you got to be
tapped in with somebody if you east
coast cripping
jack jacking the west coast you feel me
sick so i'm saying so
i heard of them feel me names was
brought up to me but i ain't get to
actually be around and [ __ ]
so that in itself for me was such a big
thing like for them to really take me in
with no problems embracing you embrace
me fully
so i'm saying like so i felt like i said
right at home
home away from home